bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa dj oggi siamo su
averi ceo che è un videogioco con un
menù molto dinamico proprio c'è una
musica madonna la musica la colonna
sonora di questo menù non vi entra in
testa tipo
ok la smetta con ragazzi avete il è un
gioco bello ecco perfetto cos'è sta roba
giorno mi presti la sposa un secondo 6
vogliano no che vi fossero una sposa la
principessa è passato comunque gioco
carino se c'è una capra c'è un fronte
sempre che mi sta leccando il ginocchio
zia e c'è una cappa posso muovermi
perché io sono forte perché c'è ok sono
caduto però va bene donna una marionetta
ia cazzo vabbè l'insalata e malvagia lo
sappiamo
oh mio dio è sta roba sono caduto di
brutto ragazzi guarda gli occhi quando
si muove bruttissimo vabbè ascolta zia
hai voglia di fare qualcosa di
produttivo
non lo so parti slittare sull'insalata
cos'è che posso fare posso parlare con
la capra o un ace buy e la call certo a
intende la tizia che è passata prima
sembrava un ragazzo cattivo con una moto
ed ha rapito la bellissima principessa
ok ok adesso è ovvio che devi salvare la
prendi la tua spada quale spada mi
sembra un buon piano dove trovare la mia
spalla si quale spada ragazzi non ho
nessuna la palla volendo posso prendere
la palla rosso si aspetta fermi
no no guarda la porta non l'ho presa
però di interessa questo frutto di
quello dato col braccio sinistra col
destro non fa niente non sta riuscendo a
prendere la palla sempre odio che cosa è
successo sono un cascato di brutto bye
bye bye bye che cazzo stai facendo di
preciso è così bravo è così che ci
dovrei fare con questa sbaglio scusa
fratello no ho preso è e vabbè madonna
che brutto dato a piccioni non riesco
neanche ad attraversare l'insalata
figurati andare a stata una principessa
che campiona ce l'ha fatta dopo secoli a
superare dell'insalata ragazzi che si
sono i problemi cioè ragazzi questo è il
è ufficialmente il gioco più difficile
che abbia mai fatto
non sono riuscito a sfondare la finestra
pro sono inciampato in compenso torniamo
in dieci si ok per così scendo le scale
io la mattina all'ora lurida finestra
che non sei al ragazzi non riescono per
una finestra si la squadra non funziona
è rotta non si riesce neanche a rompere
la finestra fantastico
non è che devo prendere tipo questa cosa
gialla roba cella che cos'è innanzitutto
che non ancora capito ma la smetti di
fare così con gli occhi che mi dai
fastidio per favore a chiamano dare sta
roba già mangiata ti sei mangiato il mio
frutto orchi mh gato qualche ragazzi c'è
un nuovo di capra incredibile ma ricopre
fanno le uova non mi pare la chiavetta
dai fate mi sembrava strano
ok per ragazzi ho preso a che cosa mi
salva di preciso non ne ho idea però c'è
lo devo ammetterlo tipo te devo
lanciarla al sì la tua passo segreta e
12 34 grazie a cosa mi serve st password
segreta di preciso allora lurida
maledetta finestra ma guarda che non c'è
per ragazzi non riesco a sfondarla ma
ediziona piazze cesta vecchio ok ti
appoggio qua è perfetto sesta roba di
precisano affermi nati o come un chiaro
a prostro coso ragazzi ok niente apposta
sia aperto attestato è perfetto
che cosa mi servirebbe la chiave di
preciso che ascolta zio ti porto una
chiave giuro che non lo sto facendo
apposta credibile se si sia aperto
[ __ ] sono capitan sparrow o da adesso
in avanti che che aria virile che ci
dispiace che la vecchia rimasta proprio
sulla merda però va beh fa niente
andiamo avanti che vengono seriamente
anche bello sono così ce la posso fare
se ce l'ho fatta col manico poi della
spalla neanche tanto fenomeno ragazzo un
genio come si fa uscire di qua morgan
secchio dammi la mano
spingi secchio spinge cosa fai qualcosa
bravo hai così se è cavaliere ragazzi se
la la principessa in buone mani e perché
mi odiano volete mai principessa sono
qui per salvarti e ti andata bene perché
sono molto valoroso non devi osare
toccare la mia principessa perché perché
io ti faccio il culo
cosa cosa diavolo è appena successo ma
chi è carini che sia in realtà io gli ho
staccato giusto un braccio è la testa e
la mano ma non sono un cazzo in spa ad
esempio forte il manico ascolta zia il
soggetto liberata andiamo a fare bunga
bunga la moto questa allora ti porterò
in salvo sulla moto perché io sono un
dongiovanni sali tesoro che cosa
tristissima ascolta zia e va bene non
sono bravo con le donne ok è il primo
appuntamento non essere così cattiva
come ti porto a cena tesoro andiamo dal
china che un posto molto romantico ti
porto io dove stiamo andando
scalda sempre bello guardare sotto la
tua come stavo scherzando non toccare la
mia donna lurido pervertito presente vai
sulla moto no no no no no eh vabbè che
chiameremo un taxi si faccia un primo
bischia e guarda e ti giuro che va beh
l'importante è che siamo insieme tesoro
è la cosa più triste con la mia mai
abbia mai giocato in tutta la mia vita
se ho vinto la vérité il fantastico dio
che succeda vérité il un gioco bello
belli cerca mi ha colpito nel profondo
dell'animo complimenti ascolta tesoro ce
ne andiamo da quel che parlano comunque
tu sei un figo e fatelo dire guarda che
bello che se io adoro i video giochi
indie per un motivo c'è belli che cazzo
sono facendo un sexy
tempo più bello da giocare scusami
ragazzi è successo di tutto in cinque
minuti di gioco non so quante durato
pochissimo io conclude ray qua ragazzi
con la lattuga tra tra le gamme è una
cosa seria avere comunque sono veramente
contento che nel 2015 videogame facciano
dei passi da gigante in avanti veramente
bravi ragazzi ha concluso fine episodio
spero che questo capolavoro videoludico
sia piaciuto quindi ragazzi servito di
più su come se i tassi documento mi
piace anche a faccia di facebook e come
ogni video trovate la descrizione se
avresti dischetto lì ci vediamo al
prossimo finito belle ragazze
[Musica]